اسلحه جديده قد تتغير الحسابات مع دخولها
المعارك الدائره في اوكرانيا انها القنابل
او الذخائر العنقوديه مبدا عمل هذه
القنابل يستند الى قيام طائره بالقاء
قنبله كبيره تسمى الحاويه وقبل وصولها الى
الارض تخرج منها مئات القنابل الصغيره
التي تنفجر ضمن نطاق يصل احيانا لمئات
الامتار المربعه
وفق التقارير الاعلاميه ستزود واشنطن
القوات الاوكرانيه بقنابل عنقوديه يمكن
اطلاقها ايضا عبر مدافع التي حازتها
اوكرانيا قبلا في هذه الحرب ولن تتعدى
نسبه احتمال عدم انفجار تلك القنابل اثنين
وخمسه اجزاء الدرجه في المئه
تستخدم القنابل العنقوديه لضرب اهداف
عديده في الوقت نفسه كالجنود والدبابات
والعربات وغيرها من الاهداف قبل ايام
تحدثت صحيفه واشنطن بوست عن تقييم
استخباراتي امريكي حصلت عليه يفيد بان
البنتا وصل قبل اشهر الى ان الاسلحه
العنقوديه يمكن ان تكون اداه فعاله ضد
تقدم القوات الروسيه وان التقييم السند
الى معطيات معارك باخموت شرقيه اوكرانيا
التي استمرت شهورا ومنها ان الجنود الروسي
يميلون الى التجمع قبل بدء الهجوم ما يزيد
من فعاليه القنابل العنقوديه التي تعادل
واحده منها فعاليه عشر قذائف مدفعيه من
عيار 155
اشار خبراء عسكريون ايضا الى ان القنابل
العنقوديه ستكون فعاله بشكل خاص ضد الحفر
او الخنادق المكشوفه في المواقع الروسيه
في حين ان خبراء اخرين اشاروا الى ان تلك
القنابل في حال عدم انفجارها وهو احتمال
وارد وان كان ضئيلا فانه سيكون عائقا امام
تقدم القوات الاوكرانيه
يذكر ان 120 دوله وقعت على اتفاقيه تحضر
استخدام القنابل العنقوديه لما ينطوي عليه
استخدامها من مخاطر كثيره على المدنيين
خصوصا الاطفال لكن الولايات المتحده
وروسيا واوكرانيا لم توقع على تلك
الاتفاقيه
[موسيقى]